all right i'm seeing security cameras i
need all that footage i need forensics
to run a full sweep
hey what are all these civilians doing
here who's responsible for securing the
area who screwed this up
hi i'm officer debbie fogle i'm so sorry
my partner's on crowd control i don't
know where he went
it's his first week on the job so he's
still learning the ropes all right
listen fogle we have a councilman in the
hospital and his shooter is still at
large we don't have time for this
incompetence i want your partner off the
case what's his name
it's raymond holt oh
it's dad i mean captain halt i mean
captain dad i mean officer holt i mean
officer dad
yep that was it officer dad i found it
detective i thought i saw our clue on
the sidewalk i apologize for not
properly securing the scene no need to
apologize i wasn't even that mad you
said you wanted whoever messed up off
the case
it doesn't matter the point is no one
needs to get in trouble look you don't
have to pity me just because madeline
once demoted me for a year i've been
stripped of my accomplishments and lost
the respect of everyone in my life
including my dog cheddar no yes
now he only poops for gavin oh cyril
officer holt
i thought i stationed you not here
right i'm just here in the plaza uh
looking for um
this a half-eaten box of mcnuggets yep
it's my lunch uh-huh and what type of
food is a mcnugget some type of uh
paella you had to know that was a bad
guess well the point is i needed my
paella and i noticed the sky bridge so
i thought i might be of some help but
i'll just go back and stand next to a
piece of police tape and do
nothing wait stop how'd you like to
stick around and assist on the case
you sure jake i mean there's only room
for one man hunter no boy's right i
don't want to overstep you're not
overstepping i mean he interrupted the
song but whatever great i'll just leave
my pie uh
on the ground saving for later we all
know that's not your lunch
clear in the back copy all clear on the
main hall clear
clear the service road or quarter mile
away is also clear
hold on there's a pigeon approaching
hold the mission
[Music]
true great work with that pidge officer
detective switched to channel five
anyone else getting a sense who's upset
about the new captain coming tomorrow
look there's no point in rebranding
yourself for the new captain
or should i say crafton because they're
not going to be here for very long
anyways remember
proud to stop it i don't want to hear
you bad-mouthing my replacement around
the office
do it surreptitiously watch this i hear
the new captain's a pill popper
they're on the way up everyone hide your
pills what a gigantic turd
agreed an unformed pile i don't know she
seemed kind of awesome to me the thing
is she can't be awesome cause she's here
to replace holt
but she said as soon as his year in
uniform is finished she's moving on
that's a pretty generous interpretation
of what she said amy as soon as this
year in uniform is finished i'll be
moving on
okay fine it's exactly what she said but
she seems like a liar someone told me
she's a pill popper pop-pop
[Music]
i'm off to walk my beat again much like
sisyphus condemned to push the same
boulder up the same hill
day in and day out you know according to
french philosopher albert camus
sisyphus achieved happiness in that
absurd repetition any french philosophy
post russo is essentially a magazine
you rube before we wrap up this briefing
i wanted to give a few shout outs
diaz great job on that b e you are a
good cop with a great attitude i don't
like this santiago
when i think of your comp stat reports
one word comes to mind
wow and that wow is an acronym for wow
oh wow what is happening he's buttering
us up before giving us some
devastatingly bad news
my god jake and charles are dead jake
and charles are not dead
it's worse than that we have to do our
annual hr seminar on workplace conflict
tomorrow
what already i know i got a bean to boil
too
santiago always tries to finish my
sentences and frequently gets it wrong
i do not and i am not wrong you do it
all
the time no i was going to say all the
day long see frequently wrong who's
ready to compete
count me in i could really use this day
off to spend some time with my husband
please we all have loved ones you're not
getting any sympathy just cause you're
gay rosa i
don't think he was no i was she saw
right through me nevertheless
i will destroy you all copy that i love
your intensity so any idea who did it no
but whoever it was had an intimate
knowledge of our security systems
it was obviously an inside job i bet it
was brian
why'd he say that because he once said
he has a hot tub
you know how that crowd is i don't know
brian hit a hot tub that does sound bad
yeah this is gonna take forever i
actually took a speed reading course i
tested at 800 wpm
that's pathetic i tested at 802. that's
pretty close to hold score no no 802 is
incredible she poned me
i read the entire urban dictionary so i
could converse with the other uniformed
officers
finished it in 47 minutes i've never
been so attracted to a gay man before
and i dated several in college so we
have a read-off santiago we don't have
finger guards so we do it raw
okay i normally don't encourage such
childish competitions but this might
help things go faster my only question
is
ho are you sure your old-ass eyes are up
to the challenge i know you're just
trying to motivate me but these old ass
eyes will be reading your tombstone
son this is ridiculous neither of you
have even taken a bathroom break
are you kidding me do you think world
record holder howard berg would stop in
the middle of a read-off
to expel oh what's going on inside the
yard
it's nothing it's my guide finger got
paper burn
let me see santiago you're hurt
don't be a hero
damn you must have been cooking i was
let's take a break put some ointment on
that
right and when i come back my finger's
slipping all over the page
nice try i'm not falling for any of your
tricks oh but you already have
while you were waggling your finger in
the air i've been reading all this time
out of the corner of my eye
damn it what's this meeting about did
someone find my meatball sub hey we
would never have a meeting about that b
you are holding it oh mindy good journey
meeting's not over dummy terry said he
has some news from the office of
commissioner wunch ugh what does that
human blister want now
does she intend to demote me even
further or perhaps she'll transfer me to
the swamps of new jersey
so i can patrol the sinkhole where she
was spawned or it's possible the
announcement has nothing to do with you
oh good thank you peralta
you're right maybe madeline wants to
inform us all that she's a chooksy
a what a chookson a korean toilet ghost
lives in an outhouse wraps her hair
around your throat and
chokes you to death while you move your
bowels you know what i will give you six
thousand dollars if the announcement is
she's a chookson
okay everyone i have some news the
madeline munch is a korean toilet ghost
boring we already knew that madeline
wuntch
is dead say what now wait lunch is dead
yeah the commissioner's office just
notified us no way that's true
as once says when she sees the old rent
i'm not buying it
sir she's dead oh terry zombies can't
die
this is some sort of scam if she were
dead we would be hearing the sounds of
children singing in the streets i don't
know sir you didn't believe it when we
told you that disco strangler died
either and i was right he was faking it
maybe she's alive
why would once fake her own death same
reason she visits mexico once a year and
sucks the blood from all the goats
for kicks look i don't know what to tell
you but she's dead but what do you want
to open up her coffin and check for
yourself
oh she's very dead ding dong
the wunch is dead bagels for
everyone so i guess you believe it now
yeah want to see the selfies i took
actually yes i'll share the album with
you oh my god i just heard about
lunch she was so young for a redwood
tree
uh i don't want to say what's going on
why are you crying a person is dead i
feel
sad that's insane you don't feel sad
when a monster dies in a monster movie
in e.t do you feel sad when e.t dies yes
he wasn't a monster he caused a real
commotion it isn't just one
i started seeing a fertility doctor and
she has me taking hormones to help with
ovulation and
my emotions aren't overdrive well i know
just the thing to cheer you up
wunch is dead bagel bagel
bagel sir i am loving this color on you
but don't you think you should tone it
down
why in case i run into her family i'm
not planning any trips to the bronx zoo
wait does this mean you're gonna be
captain again it does the chief of
personnel called to say the promotion is
in the works her death means i've won
it's finally over
[Music]
an email from madeleine wanch subject
line
it's not over oh you must be feeling
better here heating up your favorite
meal
beans they're refried it's bad enough
they were cooked once let alone twice
and now the toast arbor makes it three
times
i couldn't be crying for help any louder
so i take it you couldn't get out of
organizing wench's memorial
oh no it's impossible she has bested me
yet again well then stop being such a
[ __ ] you idiot
amy sorry it's hormones they're making
me really irritable angry amy's right
all you have to do is say a few nice
comments during the memorial as god said
when once tried to sneak past the gates
into heaven it ain't happening honey
i tried to write a kind speech about her
last night and this is what came out
oh it's like 20 pages long why is it in
all caps
so i remember to yell it oh well you
obviously can't read
any of this look since you can't say
anything nice
try saying the opposite of whatever
you're thinking interesting
i'll give it a whirl
matlin wunsch was
a friend see it's not that hard to say
something oh you're vomiting
you